this sports ground is full of tents and
mobile kitchens they help the residents
of up Jeff Kurr survive many here have
been without electricity water and
heating for days many are also hopeless
and they are bitter some are even
aggressive the constant fear is playing
on people's nerves authorities have been
handing out sweet tea and corn grads yet
only very few here are as loyal to the
state as this woman is it will be better
if they helped our soldiers and the
wounded instead and if Ukraine bought
better weapons it's estimated that as
many as 15,000 people are still left in
of Jeff Kurr this is their third winter
since the fighting began nearly everyone
here yearns for nothing but peace they
asked us soldiers when the war will
finally be over they're all fed up of
going to sleep afraid amateur footage
after shells hit a neighborhood on the
outskirts of town
Ukrainian forces and separatists often
start shooting when the darkness falls
this is one of the houses they shot at
with artillery and tanks but there are
people who live here the signs of
fighting and of death in the backyard -
civilians and 10 soldiers were killed in
after this week
the Ukrainian commander in the town
comes to inspect the damage from the
night's fighting he's especially
concerned about the city's coking plant
an attack on it could have catastrophic
consequences it would be an
environmental disaster the plant is full
of toxic substances the stretches that
carried the wounded a left outside as if
to let the rain wash away what happened
here the previous night the flare-up of
violence in eastern Ukraine has brought
a lot of suffering and destruction to
region already in agony international
relief organizations warn of an imminent
humanitarian disaster
here in FDF Kerr and other places along
the front line but the recent fighting
has also created a lot of international
awareness and this could help bring the
conflict in Donbass back on the
international agenda only a handful of
diehard optimists see it that way